avec plus d'un million de cas l'amérique
latine est devenu le principal foyer de
l'épidémie au brésil il n'y a pas
vraiment de concertation concernant les
mesures de déconfinement et le pays
compte déjà plus de 30000 morts un
chiffre certainement inférieur à la
réalité selon certains experts
le mexique lui vient de franchir la
barre des 10000 morts et le pérou et le
chili sont parmi les pays où l'expansion
de l'épidémie est la plus forte on en
parle tout de suite avec pascal dont il
est président de l'association lattes
fran france amérique latine et
vice-président de l'institut choiseul
monsieur bongo merci d'être avec nous en
direct alors qu'est ce qui se passe en
amérique latine on a l'impression que la
situation va de mal en pire et qu'elles
valent d'ailleurs s'empirer alors il est
vrai que la situation va dire sur le
plan macro est difficile ceci étant il
faut bien garder en tête que l'amérique
latine ce sont 21 pays
si vous comptez les rats la caraïbe la
région des caraïbes sans ma 33 pays cela
veut dire qu'il y a en fait une
diversité d'actions sur le continent
latino-américain ce que vous avez dit
tout a trait est tout à fait juste le
brésil aujourd'hui le deuxième pays le
plus atteint au monde à la copie de 19
vous avez rappelé les chiffres à ce jour
529 mille cas de contamination 38 58
décès à ce jour vous avez dit que les
chiffres étaient peut-être en dessous de
la réalité
c'est ce que semblent en effet indiquer
les experts et spécialistes des
questions sanitaires vous ce qui touche
au brésil ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que oui un million de cas en
amérique latine mais avec des situations
totalement disparate différentes eu
entre ses 21 états qui composent le
continent latino-américain et on a aussi
ne dessine une situations disparates
selon l'endroit où on se trouve dans un
pays soit dans une grande ville ou soit
dans une compagne reculer exactement
alors c'est vrai que le brésil
illustre ce qui pourrait être un schéma
catastrophe en amérique latine mais il
ya aussi de bons élèves
l'uruguay le paraguay le costa rica sont
arrivés à contenir la pandémie
les chiffres sont tout à fait révélateur
825 cas en uruguay 995 au paraguay 1056
au costa rica 23 décès en uruguay et au
paraguay et 10 au costa rica
donc voilà donc il y à des pays où les
choses sont sous contrôle mais en effet
le brésil pour les raisons que vous avez
indiqué d'abord la taille un bilan km²
200 millions d'habitants des tensions
très fortes et de plus en plus forte
entre les états les plus touchés je
pense notamment à sao paulo rio
notamment mais aussi l'état d'amazonas
et le pouvoir fédéral donc il est vrai
que cette lutte en amérique latine
contre la pandémie suppose une
concertation entre le pouvoir central et
ville où les épatants tourner dans un
pays fédéral un encadrement social
sanitaire est évidemment de la
discipline alors je voudrais revenir sur
le cas précis un du brésil et notamment
du président jean pierre boltz hoarau
qui a été très récemment la reprise du
championnat de football alors que son
pays est le deuxième quand même le plus
meurtri au monde
est ce qui n'est pas vraiment décalage
avec la réalité de son pays
en fait la question au brésil est
éminemment politique et je crois que la
pandémie qui touche cinq cent mille
personnes dans un pays de 200 millions
d'habitants est en fait un élément
politique la pandémie sert d'alibi à un
combat politique
un combat politique entre le pouvoir
fédéral détenu par le président paul son
art au et les états
on a l'impression qu'à une course contre
la montre est sûre avec d'étonnants de
deux lignes politiques celle de jaillir
ball sonar ou qui consiste à dire
économique économie first et la pandémie
passera et puis évidemment les états qui
sont confrontés à la situation et à
hautes tensions sociales qu'elle génère
notamment dans les mégalopoles comme sao
paulo comme des grandes villes rio mais
il y en a d'autres à porto allègre
fortaleza et manaus notamment qui est
également très touchés qui eux sont au
contact en effet d'une réalité qui est
le révélateur là aussi d'une crise
sociale de fracture sociale qui existe
au brésil comme d'ailleurs en amérique
latine je rappelle simplement que tout
indique que la crise sanitaire la
pandémie va évidemment renforcer le taux
de pauvreté au brésil ac déjà 25% mais
en amérique latine où les chiffres sont
extrêmement importants 600 millions
d'habitants en amérique latine 200
millions de pauvres
à l'issue de la crise monsieur à drouot
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'association lattes fran
france amérique latine et vice-président
de l'institut choiseul merci